what we're going to do in this video is
explore place value involving decimals
and in particular we're going to think
about how you can regroup value from one
place to another which is going to be
very useful later in your life when you
start doing some more arithmetic with
decimals so let's first think about what
this number is right over here so each
square represents a 1 or represents a
whole so what number is this well you
could see that we have three whole ones
so we could write three and then we have
right over here Oh a whole is divided
into ten equal bars these vertical bars
and so each of these are a tenth and
four of them are shaded in so it's three
ones four tenths and in this this part
right over here we've divided a hole
into a hundred equal sections it's a 10
by 10 grid and we can see that one two
three four five six seven of them are
shaded in so this represents seven
hundredths so this is three point four
seven or three four three and four
tenths and seven hundreds or three and
forty seven hundredths now what we're
going to do is explore how are other
ways you can you can put the value into
the different places so let me set up a
little a little table here I don't think
I'm going to need all that space but we
have in this first example so we have
our ones we have our ones place we have
our tenths place and we have our
hundreds hundreds hundreds place I had
to curve up a little bit and so what we
just did is we said hey this was pretty
straightforward this was three ones
three ones 4/10 and seven hundredths
700s
but are there other ways that we could
look at it for example is there a way of
reimagining this so instead of three
ones we have two ones and we still have
seven hundredths so how many tenths
would we have in order for it to be the
same value pause this video and think
about that
all right we'll do it together and to
help us I will put what we had here just
now now what's different instead of
having three ones we now have two ones
so we could say that these are our two
ones right over here our two ones we
have our seven hundredths right over
here so essentially we would have to
express all of this in terms of tenths
so how would we express it all in terms
of tenths well this what we used to be a
1 this is equivalent to 10 tenths let me
make that very clear
I could see let me see if I could shade
this in with that green color so there
you go I'm gonna show you with the green
color and then let me draw a bunch of
lines here to make it very clear so I'm
just gonna hand draw it so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and 10 did I do that right 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 and I didn't draw it as
straight as I need to it they really
should be 10 equal sections but it was
hand drawn so I think you understand and
so look notice I took the exact same
value but I have regrouped I have
regrouped this one right over here into
tenths and so how many tenths are here
well now I have 10 plus 4 tenths so now
I have shaded in four teen tents that
was interesting let's do another example
so now let's imagine another scenario
let's imagine a Sarah where we have
three ones again but this time instead
of having seven hundredths we have 27
hundredths so in that circumstance how
many tenths would we have pause this
video and see if you can work it through
all right well let's get that same
number again and now let's think about
how we might have to regroup between the
places so we have our three ones so that
was just like the first case right over
there so we have our three ones but now
we have 27 hundredths so in addition to
these seven hundredths we have to find
another 20 hundredths someplace well the
most natural place to go would be right
over here and
hundreds is the same thing as two tenths
so what we want to do is we would
convert these two tents into hundreds
and so let me actually just shade it in
a little bit so I'm going to convert
this right over here to hundreds and so
they did that right one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten and so
there you have it this Plus this gives
us our twenty seven hundredths and so
how many tenths do we have left we have
two tenths two tenths so in this
situation we regrouped to from the
tenths place and we express them as
hundredths so two tenths became 20
hundredths add it to the seven
hundredths that you already have and we
now have 27 hundredths hopefully that
makes sense